yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing tiger paw brazil so okay it's a
funny sight line here in the English I
think the snider three castles is pretty
good it's a completely unknown but I
think it's fairly good here you will
have problems with the e4 pawn just
keeping this point it's not an easy task
as we will see i hope so 95 is possible
on or d 3 t3 that's a 3some quincy to
policy coverage have to consider 94 can
be one Bishop before something like mad
hey maybe I'm getting in trouble you had
this of this first and then take it
check okay so grab this big porn okay i
have before you actually supported by
the queen but okay deep deep also is bad
I wonder if before is actually good
threatening see fried I think it's it
cannot be bad so let's get this going in
[Music]
get this play on the queenside
yeah be sure where do I put the bishop
to a three yeah these six look weak so
let's put some pressure on the pawn
one day about 98 for this is an idea
it's probably not bad but ok let's
connect rooks here I have to do this at
one point yeah it's nice to have the
palm but currently the e porn ok it
covers d forward it isn't really oh okay
that makes things a bit simpler black
resigned so let's have a quick look at
the opening which it was just a little
bit more than opening the skin yet h6 is
a funny line it looks a little bit
exotic but the thing is on 93 is the
normal move and then we should be form
is played and age six actually does make
some sense and in many cases so when I
was analyzing this I was thinking why
not Knight f3 and ask like a question
about this pawn I think white is in good
shape after this move like here here
he's a bit running out of ideas and what
to do something back d 5 is just a
normal line with age 62 being a temple
down so this is kind of understandable i
do you have problems to keep this porn
cd3 is actually right okay i didn't
didn't quite remember how it works yeah
but this this this yeah he had Bishop
before yeah but I couldn't every think
I'll go back to d1 okay it's not
terrible actually maybe to go back to
the one as e3 is a threat id3 is also a
threat so maybe 21 was actually
better than here d three years good him
okay I was irritated by this move but
yeah well the engine check check shows a
clear edge for white and yeah it really
looks nice the f file is open nurse 95
and white is much better development we
have the way it was it was just a born
up for with a very nice pollution to
boot down until the queen is a queen ok
guys thanks for watching